[Music]
this is how you speak the deal sources
sources got deals it's okay to buy from
them
but
hey how you doing man
in the in the deals a little bit of a
little bit of background
um about my situation
so it found these properties then about
themselves and i saw
he's done all the work on him i think
we're talking about the price in that
where we and he's not out of rick's
family or an estate agent he's just
based at the moment on his shield
so he's just been a mixed combination of
uh
what it's achieving uh stress testing it
on like 450 a month per room
but realistically it's only got two
tenants in there we're paying 500 and
520
so it can it you know that's what it can
achieve
so what what do you think the current
the current so basically the situation
is
they're on for 240 each or 450 000 for
the two of them together they're both
five bit hmos
what do you what do you think the
current value is right now
i think they're too expensive yeah
i don't think it's too expensive and
i've gone back i've gone back and told
him this
now he does work with his business
partner so he's having to think about it
now i've said it needs to be he has had
an offer forward on one of them
for around 220 i believe which he
he said no to but i think if someone
came forward for a combined
vote there you know around like that i
don't know i would say it needs to be of
online about the 220
property at 240's out the question
yeah yeah and and what what do you think
because obviously it's all with him
saying this is my bet my evaluation
based on the rent and based on this but
obviously he's the seller he'll say
anything i need to try and get sale
like if because the thing is what would
be annoying would be if we bought them
and then they because because if
especially if we're buying two of them
if we find two of them it's a lot of
cash we'd mortgage them but then if it
just got down valued um it's just a
waste of time isn't it for it for you
for for the seller all right for
everybody i'll get you on that one okay
on that one so and that's one trying to
work out like what the
what the bricks and mortar valuation
might be is the bricks and mortar
evaluation going to be really low
because of the area or
i mean is it being forced as the value
force up based on a potential commercial
valuation which might not never come to
anything
yeah well that's the thing you see is
it's a mix this combination of the next
i mean five beds aren't going for that
price
you know the people are selling five
beds between between the 200 and 250
mark so it's
it is an average price uh it's just
the conversations i've been having with
the people who've been looking in the
past it's more to do with
they see it as expensive because you can
buy a rundown power for about 120 pounds
in the area and do the conversion
yourself
now obviously that's a different
strategy as you know so yeah there's no
point trying to think that way on these
because these are just
these are for somebody who wants to buy
a ready-made setup and it's gonna
you know cash so nicely it's solid thing
is the price point now isn't it
yeah i mean so so so
let's just say we did buy them for 240
each um which you're saying you think we
could get it lower than that but
what did you say the rent is so let's
say on average 450 a room is there five
beds did you say
yeah yeah at the moment the two because
they've literally just finished one of
them is empty because the furniture is
not even in it yet
yeah so the one that has finished it's
got two minutes straight away now
they're paid
for 520. okay so are they all on sweet
rooms
all on the switch would there be
anything we're talking about 30 grand
property um yeah it could work i mean at
the moment we're looking to
to to play with 200 grand so this would
just have to be like a literally dump
the money in
get a mortgage um you know
dump the money in and then and then it
could work
it could work quite nicely yeah but i'll
do is i'll send you a send your
screenshot
equip with the quick figures and bits
and pieces um
whereabouts are they chris where abouts
and the other ones the other ones we've
got and they're approved
they're they are these are the ones that
are left for housing associations
now one's a block of six flats but he's
you know it's about
450 mark again but it's a block of six
so
you're actually better off monthly
getting these two hmos
versus this one for the same value and
the other one
is
crochet based on a million pound basket
okay
it's not terrible no it's quite good
like
it actually said though it's got the
housing association in it so
there's no they paid the maintenance
bills as you know
so this the profit margins on that is
exceptionally honest
so they want a million quid what what's
the what's the guaranteed rent each year
uh it's the guaranteed rent is i mean
the flats
pull in 86 or 84 000
and and and and there's no costs on that
apart from insurance and mortgage
exactly okay so this brand new
brand news just being renovated so if we
pull that from
we need to put in probably about would
you say about
40 percent well i've been speaking with
jimmy higgs and he's been he's managed
to be able to sort things out
quite creatively where you're not you're
not having to put down 40 percent
deposit you're important down to 20
deposit 20 that well that would be
amazing
if you put down 200 grand and you got
that and it was bringing in
and you said it's bringing in 86 grand a
year
rent collectively because you you'd have
to communicate units as well
uh you're talking 106 pounds a year that
sounds good
yeah i mean that's what i've been trying
to have a conversation about that one as
well
if these hmos don't work yeah i think so
it's good to have a choice isn't it and
the thing is chris like if you've got
two or three choices i'll be able to
sort of almost just stick with you if
you've just got one option then i'll
have to find
your option then i have to find another
option then i have to find another
option
and then and then we'll decide what's
best but if you've got two or three it
means that you're more likely to get the
deal you know what i'm saying
yeah well what how do you want to send
this to you if you have a personal email
or
uh yeah i do yeah
that's it yeah and also depending on
what i'm doing and how busy i am and
what how how hungry i am for a deal like
if i don't respond it probably just
means i'm not super interested
potentially
but like you know if there's anything
really juicy chase me for it
so these hmos then what do you think the
chances are i can get a virtual viewing
on them today
we can get the hmo's today i've asked to
see if you could postpone he said yes to
1 45 but
we have to postpone it to three o'clock
now don't we uh i'm waiting for him to
get back to say yes on that
three o'clock would be would be perfect
if you could get that i'll put the
groundwork in for a
lower price and i'll also get the email
sent here for these other cool deals so
you can have a look through the figures
at least
all right jay appreciate your help
that's the thing you know don't pay a
deal saucer
if you don't know what you're doing if
you're clueless
and then you just find a deal source and
go find me a deal you're not paying a
deal saucer for their
skills you're paying them really for
their time i haven't got time to
continually drive back and forth up
north
and and be viewing everything and
crunching numbers myself i'm paying deal
sources
so they can present nice deals pass them
to me i'll look at them and then
if it stacks up and if it looks good i
know the right questions to ask
they know the right questions to ask me
the only reason i'm able to ask
questions and have a conversation like
that is because
the people i'm speaking to and i'm
serious i'm showing them my proof of
phones
i've bought from them many times before
so if you've got a good relationship
with deal sources and agents if
you know what you're doing then and only
then would i recommend
paying deal sources to start finding
your deals if you haven't got that
position yet
then get educated so you can get to that
point when you're at that point
there's nothing sweeter than just paying
deal sources to bring you deals it's a
great feeling